that's what girls will say like okay for  example Sierra right in a way she she  raised her price a bit and she she ended  up with like I'd say Russell is a better  husband than future but that that works  if you're hot  I mean maybe you could afford to do that  yeah that's what I'm saying like I'm not  saying I don't think it works the  majority of the time everyone looks at  Russell as a samp but the girls that it  works out for you by the way are what I  think he's the same yeah yeah but the  girls that it works out for are  extremely hot that's not gonna look work  for the average girl and so they'll look  at girls that do that that are hotter  than them and think oh if I do that then  I could but it's like nah it ain't you